Information wants to be free!
But if that free information is a calorie
count for my favorite donut, then lock it
up! Lock it up!
You know what i mean?
We are living in the ultimate age of information
… you’re watching this video because you
have access to an awesome portal of collective
knowledge called the internet.
And having more information can often help
us make better choices.
Which is all well and good except for the
fact that humans are not always information
seekers.
Sometimes we even avoid information that could
help us!
For instance, you probably have an idea about
how much money you’ve spent lately, but
you might avoid actually looking at your bank
account so you don’t see the exact amounts
you splurged on a new purse.The information
is riiight there, but you just don’t want
to know.
And not knowing might have consequences.
This psychological phenomenon is called “active
information avoidance.”
You’re actively avoiding information when
these three things happen: you know the information
exists, it could be costly to avoid, but you
still go out of your way to ignore it.
A recent paper from Carnegie Mellon University
found that people have a wide variety of strategies
to avoid information and they do it to protect
themselves...And this seems like a no-brainer,
people avoid information that might be painful
to receive.
We don’t want to know how many calories
are in that hot fudge sundae because we want
it and it looks amazing.
We don’t want to know it’s 1,000 calories
because knowing that number might deter us
from having it.
Might.
Avoiding the calorie counts in a dessert happens,
we all do it because we need to live a little
... but what are the consequences of avoiding
something more serious… like medical issues?
Another study looked at people who were at
risk for Huntington's Disease, a fatal brain
disorder, and found that a large fraction
of people avoided getting tested.
Carnegie Mellon researchers called this: an
optimism bubble.
Basically, people won’t get tested because
they want to live their lives without fear
or consequence; they don't want their bubble
bursted.
This is why people don’t get tested for
cancer, why people don’t follow the news
-- they want to live in a optimism bubble!
But… living there isn’t living in reality
-- think about sexually transmitted infections.
If i’m living in my optimism bubble, I could
be infecting others.
And speaking of bubbles -- this extends to
how we reinterpret information that counters
our beliefs.
For example, there’s a growing body of scientific
research that is widely available disproving
the link between vaccines and autism.
And yet, a bunch of unscientific websites
linking the two are cited by people who already
believe vaccines cause autism.So even if the
data is right there, it will be discounted
if it goes against what people want to believe.
Active Information Avoidance is a psychological
protection strategy because we’ve spent
months or years building brain pathways and
patterns of behavior around our worldview.
Changing those pathways takes energy and work
-- it causes stress, and uncertainty!
Avoiding it is so much easier (though not
necessarily better).
So what should we do about this?
How do we break out of being active information
avoiders?
Well, according to the researchers at Carnegie
Mellon, if you want to change someone’s
mind make a personal relationship with them
first!
If you form a meaningful relationship with
a friend you could maybe remind them to get their prostate checked
for cancer, or breast cancer checks. You could remind them to keep tabs on their finances
Or, maybe not to eat that sundae.
If you know you’re avoiding information
-- maybe try and work a little hard to, well,
not.
For example, you might try and avoid information
about why New York has the best bagels.
Water?
Location?
Tradition?
It’s a debate.
I LOVE bagels.Thrillist just launched a brand
new show Food/Groups.
My buddy Dave hits up a cast of food experts
as they hunt down a dish that’s authentically
tied to a different neighborhood, nationality,
or lifestyle.
Check out his bagel adventure here I love
Essa, that place.
Omg.
But let’s say you’re in an argument, and
you want to convince your friend you’re
right -- science has the best way to do that!
In this video over here.
What information do you definitely avoid?
Let us know in the comments and subscribe
to Seeker for more videos.